but Julie you've been working with Tiger
King right you've been interviewing all
the people like printf lakes right yeah
no I I can't I I'm holding onto the the
coattails of that documentary they asked
me to host the you know that kind of rap
the ketchup special and see where
everybody was that was agreeing to be on
camera and so they asked me a few days
before it aired and we quickly scrambled
together and got they had a bunch of
people ready to be interviewed so I you
know I had barely anything I I was just
happy to do it because I loved the
series and was fascinated by it and I
got to talk to a lot of the folks
involved and yeah it's after anything
I've done in the business for the last
20 years nothing compared to the
response of that I've never been a part
of anything that was that popular ever
I'm not combined the soup and community
not even close to 140 minute special of
me going how's Oklahoma so that's that's
basically House on the Prairie like
things before time you are going to
you're in a dark place if you're needing
that cut it you're like oh you're going
way back like I'm going back before
Korona I was like you could done you
could have done er I mean that was 25
years ago but you decided to go back
almost 40 years subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going